[موسيقى]
تنفس الالمان الصعداء بعد نشر بيانات
وكاله الطاقه الفيدراليه في المانيا
بامتلاء منسوب خزانات الغاز الالماني
لتصيله الى نسبه
99% وفقا لاحدث البيانات
[موسيقى]
فرحه الالماني لم تكتمل بعد تحضيرات رئيس
الوكاله الاتحاديه الالمانيه للشبكات
كلاوس مولر من احتمالنا هذه المخزون بسرعه
اذا جاء الطقس في الشتاء شديد البروده دعى
الالمان للتوفير في الاستهلاك واستخدام
وسائله
[موسيقى]
مخزونات والغاز الحاليه تكفي لمعاصره عمل
اكبر اقتصاد في اوروبا فقط لتسعه او عشره
اسابيع بشرط ان يكون الشتاء متوسطه
البروده كما كان الحال في العام الماضي
اوروبا استعدت ايضا الى حد مالي مواجهه
هذا الشتاء مع خزانات غاز شبه ممتلئه وصلت
نسبتها نهايه اكتوبر الى
95% لكن كيف تغلبت اوروبا على ازمه الطاقه
هذا العام استطعت اوروبا الوصول لهذه
المستويات من خلال دعم واردات الغاز
الطبيعي
الاوروبيين بالازمه وفي ظل طقس معتدل خلال
اكتوبر وهو الى نوفمبر اما خفف من المخاوف
بشانه نقص امدادات الطاقه هذا الشتاء
واجلها من شتاء العام المقبل برنامج صباح
العربي ايهم القاسم الماضي